Norah's interview with South Korean
president moon jae-in was a major topic
of conversation in South Korea we have a
look at some of the newspapers from
Seoul where Norah O'Donnell made
front-page news this is a Korean Times
with a shot of nor in the president this
is my favorite though this is a Korean
newspaper nor on my high my high school
Korean is failing me nailed now but I
think it says Charlie Norah O'Donnell
CBS's Norah O'Donnell Wow South Korea
Charlie and Gayle wonder when she coming
back to the table not what it says to
you yeah I remember my Korean shows
exactly what is it I know one word in
Korean and what it is what is it Charlie
what is it I didn't morning that's right
on y'all say o our bride one quick
question yet is the reaction in South
Korea different than the reaction here
in the United States I know I did I
actually think it's it's quite similar I
mean they were in this was really his
only in first big one-on-one interview
so there was so much news of course
about Ottawa beer and everything he said
about the upcoming trip to the White
House that's a possibility of a freeze
yeah so it made a lot of news there too
is interesting everybody seemed to know
my name on Wednesday
do they oh look Nora they're a couple
people asking for pictures the next day
yeah the timing that you were there but
really Bravo to you we were all in the
studio applauding really good job thank
you thank you to back thank you and we
should mention that while we were in
South Korea the US military took us
aboard a helicopter to see what's at
stake in Seoul it is one of the most
densely populated cities in the world
in fact Seoul is less than 40 miles from
the North Korean border u.s. army gave
us a first-hand look at how it's
countering threats from the north right
now where the aircraft is we're right in
the center of Seoul we hitched a ride
from Yongsan garrison on a pair of Black
Hawk helicopters for a bird's-eye view
of the metropolis less than 40 miles
from the North Korean border about 25
million people just goes at me to the
horizon unbelievable
it's back in New York City 8th army
chief of staff Colonel William Taylor
says it's all within reach of Kim Jong
Un's artillery what kind of damage could
long-range artillery do a lot it's very
destructive you know very destructive
one study estimates about 2,800 people
could die in an initial volley of
artillery fire and some 64,000 lives
could be lost if it continued for an
entire day
Major General Tammy Smith says that's
one of the reasons the military is
moving its headquarters 40 miles south
to Camp Humphreys get out of the range
of the long-range artillery images it
removes that immediate threat at a
sprawling 3,400 acres
Humphreys is the largest peacetime
construction project in US military
history with South Korea picking up over
90 percent of the bill we landed a short
distance away at Osan Air Base a young
man unmarked plenty on the commander 65
to 80 a home of the 35th air defense
Artillery where you see here is we're
doing a pack 3 missile reload their
motto is ready to fight tonight we saw
soldiers preparing Patriot missiles to
shoot down incoming ballistic missiles
from North Korea how accurate is it it's
very accurate very very
in the Gulf War the Patriot missile had
just a nine percent success rate but
Lieutenant Colonel mark Pollini says
it's now a key piece of protection so we
are truly the first line of defense we
buy decision space for the President and
for the CFC commander general Brooks to
make decisions on how to potentially
de-escalate or escalate the conflict as
necessary in the face of international
condemnation North Korea has conducted
10 missile tests this year two of them
involved solid fuel missiles which the
north can launch with less warning why
do these solid fuel Rockets make it
harder because it doesn't require as
much preparation for them to take a
missile and and prepare it and get it
ready for launch
Colonel Rick Wright took us inside an
engagement control station where the
pressure would be on to shoot down any
incoming threat so this is where they
would essentially push the button to
launch it absolutely this is where the
tactical control officer and his
assistant could actually execute the air
battle we routinely exercise that from
the phone call that would come in to me
to actually moving them on the road to
potentially putting a missile up in the
air how quickly can you do that I can do
it pretty pretty fast you practice that
we practice it we press it very
routinely so really interesting to hear
that phrase to decision space you know
they're the front line of defense so
that if they have to respond in another
way they could give commanders that time
to do that before the president has to
make his final decision yeah it's just
interesting though to see the real
people behind all the military stories
that we report to see how proud they are
the job they're doing and to get to meet
them Gail I almost got a little choked
up talking to some of them because you
remember these are the most honorable
people they serve their country away
from their family sometimes and just
really right there in harm's way part of
one of the most critical tests of the
United States right now absolutely yeah